mon rêve quand j'étais petit mon rêve
juste c'était une Porsche une Porsche
une porte
et quand j'ai gagné ma vie quand j'ai eu
un quand j'ai gagné ma vie correctement
j'ai acheté une Porsche et j'étais comme
un fou ah ouais j'ai téléchargé au
magasin je passais quand j'étais petit
devant et un jour un jour j'aurai ma
porte ce magasin je suis rentré dans ce
magasin et je me suis acheté ma porte et
j'ai eu un kiffe monument alors quand tu
rentres il ferme la porte alors je n'en
revanche
ferme le rideau ferme le rideau je le
connais ferme le rideau c'est fini j'ai
plus de voiture non mais c'est c'est
quoi ton maxime a acheté une belle île
déserte Nil une petite flottante
dans les Maldives passer six mois de
l'année là-bas et profitez hein
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le gars est né ringard
oh mon Dieu
tu partiras avec qui là-bas ah Kelly
avec toute l'équipe alors bien sûr
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur une île déserte vous finissez par
vous embrouiller frère c'est obligatoire
frère
l'amour avec Madame
vulgarités
après tu te réconciles et après tu vas
chercher des noix de coco
je te dis tu tiens pas de moi
je te le dis
[Applaudissements]
ta gueule dans l'eau qui va bientôt
après trois noyaux
tu vas voir tu vas revenir ici tu vas
être content tu vois
Kelly c'est quoi vous est-ce que vous
achèteriez
j'achèterai un magasin un magasin ouais
j'ai envie de vendre des trucs plein de
trucs n'importe quoi je vous vend des
choses je
suis une énorme n'importe quoi des
fringues des fruits des légumes des
ouais des fois
une tomate et la chemise là-bas
[Rires]
vous avez des melons bien frais d'accord
bah vous mettez les ballons il est à
combien le chemisier là-bas
vous mettez ça d'accord va très bien
c'est génial on fait comme ça on part
comme ça d'accord
Daniel par exemple elle achète ses
chaussures en pharmacie
quand tu es très vieux tu achètes tes
j'ai du club clamoxyde doliprane et vous
les avez ça en 38
avec une meuf et qu'elle s'arrête devant
les chaussures en vitrine de la
pharmacie ça vous est déjà arrivé c'est
mort
ouais moi ça m'est déjà arrivé avec ma
grand-mère oui alors regardez frère
était comme un frère ma grand-mère
devant les chaussures de pharmacie frère
on dirait qu'elle était devant le devant
chez Louboutin
c'était Jimmy chou frère
non mais sans déconner c'est vrai frère
elle était chez Dior la meuf était
tu regardes quoi les dolipranes non non
pas mal bah écoute
et quand tu commences à mettre des
chaussures c'est les chaussures pour
randonner tu vois comment s'acheter tes
chaussures au Vieux Campeur
pas bon du tout frère pas bon du tout ça
dépend si vous faites un trekking
déjà c'est que c'est pas bon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pris le bâton je suis mis dans le
cul
et je l'ai fait tourner comme ça avec
son des connaisseurs j'en ai fait une
barbe à papa
sans déconner non mais arrêtez les gars
non mais attendez franchement de sport
là-haut les gars qui font du trek mais
pas trop
non mais pas tout le temps c'est c'est
eux toi c'est voilà toi tu fais quoi
comme sport pourquoi tu fais pas un
sport dans le noir toi
[Rires]
là je suis prêt là tu es prêt à quoi en
fait
je suis prêt on a vu avec le mec du MMA
on l'a vu
les derniers combats on a vu que tu
étais bien prêt